let's look at new polling in Walker
versus Warnock now I want to remind you
most of the polling here is still
pre-abortion Scandal but the race has
already turned in Rafael warnock's favor
and that's a very good thing since
yesterday there have been two new polls
there is a Fox 5 Insider Advantage poll
which has Warnock plus three and then
there is a wxia TV survey USA poll which
has Rafael Warnock plus 12. these are
the only two polls currently that
include any of October but what's really
important is that the survey USA poll by
the way survey USA has an a rating on
538 the survey USA poll includes some
October but 95 of the poll was conducted
before the abortion bombshell story
involving Herschel Walker these new
numbers still don't fully include
um the full effect of the Herschel
Walker abortion story and if you look at
the chart you see the red line Herschel
Walker almost a vertical decline while
Raphael Warnock is benefiting from this
decline this is not about using personal
dirt to hurt candidates this is about
Walker has no business being in the
United States Senate and the Georgia
voters are so weaponized by the
disinformation that has been shot at
them that they don't know Up Is Down
Down is up day is night they don't know
what's going on and they are using
special pleading and they are using
selective enforcement of their supposed
values to continue saying I like
Herschel Walker it seems as though some
of them
some of them are bailing by Monday by
Monday my prediction is the polling will
put walker even further down but in the
meantime we assume nothing
everyone must vote don't stay home
etc etc our sponsor magic spoon is the
breakfast cereal that tastes amazing but
without the sugar carbs and the crazy
ingredients magic spoon has taken your
favorite childhood cereals and
brilliantly transformed them into
something you can feel good about eating
because each serving has zero grams of
sugar under five net carbs and is packed
with 13 grams of protein so it'll work
for keto and low carb but it's really
perfect for anyone who wants the
occasional sweet crunchy treat without
the sugar their portfolio of eight plus
unique delicious flavors allow you to
never get bored my favorite is maple
waffle but they've got the classics like
cocoa fruity frosted also cinnamon roll
blueberry muffin our entire team has
been eating magic spoon for years we
love it but if you don't they send you
all your money back it's really easy
magic spoon has been supporting the
David pakman show for a long time they
always give my audience five dollars off
when you go to magicspoon.com Pacman and
use the code Pacman the link is down
below